How many of you believe that nature has
a balance,
that nature is this fine,
liberal,
even beautiful,
complicated tapestry of interrelated
things that all lien one against the
other and make it all perfect and
wonderful.
Because if you do,
and it's what George Bailey's is,
you're entirely wrong.
Nature works on Cataclysm and accident.
We all,
we are all competitive.
We were born competitive.
We grew up competitive.
We were evolved from competition.
There is no right way for the world to
be.
There was no moment where George's world
was just keep it there,
don't move.
I think that
there was no marvelous time when the up
plans with just that nice little bit of
woodiness and not too many festivals and
it didn't exist.
We all get on because something else
fails.
The natural role in existence is to lead
to extermination.
That's what happens to most things.
We've been immensely successful as a
species.
That's not our fault.
That's our brilliance.
Yeah.
What I mind about George's view of the
world is that there is nature and then
there's us,
there's everything else.
There's all the glory,
and then there's me
greedy,
fat farting.
Slovenly slothful,
uncaring twat eating things with eyes.
I am as much part of nature as every
other species here in this world.
All of us are,
and what I mind about this view of the
way the world works is it stopped me
being part of my birthright,
which is part of natural selection.
It makes me a fucking zoo keeper,
and I don't want to be a park ranger in
your park.